Ярік
[музика]
[оплески]
взагалі не хочу їхати до Херсона тут
так клас по домашньому ми зможемо
корінні херсонці живемо тут березня
взагалі не хочу їхати
[музика]
а Яша надав Пітера а зупиніться
літера я
літера про
млинець не дадуть у темряві згущеного молока
нажраться літературі Skyrim тупо не
видно
[музика]
Давай вимкнемо світло
е у нас світла може поїсти
і наполони
один два три
[музика]
ідіотом та моїм просто сидить
поста камін російські книжки
а душевно нарустав
[оплески]
[музика]
дуже радий прокидаюся
[оплески]
в основному так
[музика]
Україні молодий чоловік
[оплески]
інструкція як стати
напасти на суверенну державу
[музика]
отримати
ще раз отримати ще раз отримати
ще раз отримати зрозуміти що ви нікчемні
програєте війну Усвідомити, що воювати
ви здатні лише з мирним населенням
обстрілювати мирні міста крилатими
ракетами радіти руйнуванням та загибелі
мирного населення дивуватися прокляттям
на свою адресу закликати використовувати
ядерну зброю
[музика]
на 5 рублів
20 Цибулько 15 кріп
[музика]
Як метафора телеку хотіла сказати ще
сама апарату
Шкоду трави якось
так так Ну так зрозуміло Так прикольно
прикольно
[музика]
чекайте нашим
відривається район
[музика]
[оплески]